everyone I'm Alana and I got to play Ori
and the blind forest at Gamescom so Ori
and the blind forest is in upcoming the
side-scrolling platformer with it has
you control Ori a little spirit that
totally looks like a baby version of
toothless from How to Train Your Dragon
and this is the most adorable thing ever
it has some super metroid and journey
phleb largely reminded me of the recent
ub arts game child of lakme an
atmosphere sound and I style so yeah
it's so damn pretty but little Ori is
going through some tough business biting
creepy bad guys within the forest
reasons not yet fully explained oryza
parent/guardian gets kidnapped by the
bad guy Kuro and already starts a rescue
mission initially though you have a
really small amount of abilities or e is
weak and powerless and eventually gets
helped out by a sprite called st. as
well as slowly leveling up throughout
the game
though what I saw is quite brief the
level system seems like it's going to be
a pretty important part of this game you
automatically unlock the skills you need
to progress in the game so you can spend
your actual experience points you earn
through combat and a handful of other
things on whatever the hell you actually
want stuff for more help to new combat
abilities or some more passive skills
like causing certain things within the
game to gravitate towards you it's
actually all pretty broad with loads of
skills to choose from and I'm personally
always thankful for that kind of thing
as for the game itself that's where it
kind of functions like Metroid you can
go wherever you really want some areas
inaccessible without the right abilities
to actually get you that then kind of
like Zelda you get a new ability in each
level and then you'll need to master the
ability to actually face the challenges
before you instead of a bus fight though
it's more about environmental changes
which looks surprisingly intense
I did initially find the game to be
quite simple and I guess a little bit
too easy but hey I was playing the first
level in the entire game which was
obviously intended to be an introduction
some of the abilities available and how
they affect the way you traverse through
levels and the way levels are catered to
certain abilities is exciting so while
it's a pretty little game with a pretty
little protagonist I'm betting awaiting
for a challenge here in the end and I'm
keen for it Ori and the blind forest set
to release later this year on the xbox
one and next year on the xbox 360 so
this will be the last of my games come
videos if I can scrap together some
footage I will also make like a more
vlog style one even though it's kind of
delayed now and I did get to play some
other games that I didn't talk about
like dying light but I can get to play
enough of that for me to feel
comfortable talking about it and also
Assassin's Creed unity but what I played
it was really really broken not fault of
the game it's just probably still very
beta so there was like heaps of getting
stuck in walls but I hope you guys have
enjoyed all these videos thank you for
joining me on the awesome journey of
games come and i'll see you guys next
time